hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the cursed forest
now as you can see I got my setup going
here and I got my webcam finally I was
out all day I was busy setting up my
entire office here to record and get it
ready now I gotta be careful about being
too too loud because not all the
soundproofing is engaged so hopefully I
don't scream my itty-bitty panties off
but we just got out of the house I had
to play through the whole game again
because I didn't have the game with the
checkpoints on this computer and I
actually tried because someone mentioned
that there was an English patch to this
game but I tried that and it threw up a
lot of errors so I'm just gonna continue
the game through this it's been a lot of
people that have been saying in the
comments below what has been happening
so if you want to know more about the
story check the comments of other people
vote up the good ones that actually have
a reasonable stuff and then I take a
wrong turn was i okay I think I'm
supposed to go back now wait a minute no
no no no okay I need to remember because
it's been a bit I got that I'm only
missing the head bone and the other part
of the leg I think I've gotten about
four or three or four stones I've got
the torso and spine I've got the hip
bone both arms one leg one leg and one
femur and I believe I just need the
skull and the shin and foot if it'll get
me in a combo package that would be even
more delightful now I was playing
through this whole game again alone in
my new room in the dark so yeah hey
someone not having happy fun times up in
that cottage of our cottage treehouse of
horror Horrors tree house of horrors
isn't that a thing
hello gonna reap up and rip up my head I
cannot talk I cannot talk okay but
anyway as you can see I've got my lovely
soundproofing over here and hopefully
the echo is in - tremendous I've got my
nice quiet computer it is amazing how
quiet this computer actually is and in a
way it is so much more powerful so much
more compact
excuse me
that was a bucket you can't tell me that
that was normal okay I don't want to
pick you up cuz I have a feeling that
something bad is gonna happen
hello mr. bucket I don't have an option
to pick you okay all right you know what
I'm gonna assume that was the least
weird thing that happened to do that was
the least weird thing that happened in
this entire forest of goodness and
happiness oh good more lights
I'm sure they'll go off soon we'll have
another episode of a guy chasing me wait
a minute what the hell what is this a
military base in the middle of the woods
this forest is not okay I see a red glow
but I heard something
swear it came from to the right alrighty
then bring it on mr. shadowy past - here
I'll bring it on I'm just kidding I'm
braver than that it's good take a lot
more than a few rattles and broken
alrighty then did I not get enough I
think I see the skull over there if that
actually is the skull fine we'll go this
way
the way the light bulb burn out in damn
look at this what is going on here hey
knock knock
Girl Scout cookies coming in I've got a
whole bunch more soundproofing going on
soon I'm gonna soundproof this balcony
window over there and/or the knob
balcony we knew the sliding doors and
then I'm gonna soundproof the actual
door to this room and then I'm gonna
sound truth whose ceiling and then I'm
gonna soundproof I'm gonna give me not
quite used to see my microphone setup -
I forgot to get the microphone stand so
it's on a beanbag and an old hard drive
box I have completely jury-rigged okay
the earth is upset I've jerry-rigged
everything in this entire room but it is
working phenomenally Oh like it is so
nice to have top-of-the-line stuff okay
oh that's another stone that that might
be the I'm going in a house again I'm
all gonna be stuck here for about ten
hours
[Music]
that's normal oh yeah that's normal what
happened I don't know what happened I
have no idea oh I don't think I want to
know I don't think I want to go in that
room get up
and what Oh laugh at me what are you an
old lady is that what you actually are
I didn't read what it said can someone
tell me what that said it's too small
get up and smell the roses get up in
there
Magritte today get up and put shoes on
your feet get up and butter your butt
your hair or whatever what are both well
I care and the earth is angry again okay
so I got stones I just need that skull
but I swear I haven't gotten the other
part of the foot I don't even know where
that is but I'm almost done with this
stupid Skellington that makes no ding
dong dam Dingle cents give me up there
now where does that go
is that what I'm supposed to take the
railway to whatever man you know for
being the same woods or forest or
whatever you want to call this this is
amazingly intricate for what they got
going on here there's a lot of detail
put into it when they could have been
super lazy about
that coming from when there could have
been super lazy about in just like done
regular old normal everyday woods things
like or they or he whoever did this if
this is one guy that is amazing is that
a red glow over there please tell me it
is this is July for this hello ah looks
like another boy you are a dead man and
if you get up you'll be deader I'm gonna
get a paint get up
[Music]
oh no we're moving I need to get out
what happened alrighty then what's over
here wood in the woods Lords it uh what
did I see something there was there
actually something there I think this
developer planned it this way there's
all these like little white dots in the
woods that I think are eyes but then
they're not and then I I look like an
idiot in front of the entire Internet
smart but I am kind of and very smart so
I think I think the guy from the thing
sure I'm gonna walk him here hole I
shouldn't have summoned a demon the
beginning of this lets play playthrough
whatever you want to call it this thing
okay I think I think it wants me to go
there now if it was cliche and be the
hole oh no a train coming out of the
turtle run that ol thing
alright I'm gonna think hire this guy oh
my kids II think I'm gonna happen
okay see that barrel oh it is dark in
here okay no hole can see anything okay
let's go
[Music]
oh man that got my adrenaline pumping
rate he then Oh what the hell no no no
no no no no let me get the bone why did
you put me all the way over here maybe I
wasn't supposed to go in that tunnel I
think I just need to get this other
piece of the piece of the leg I've
already gotten one favor I'm because the
other femur I didn't see a foot ah I
didn't get it for me fine oh that tunnel
pretty sure that I'm danceable to go the
tunnel at all oh hey
hey buddy how's it hanging then actually
mover was that just my brain telling me
that it was moving what hit it
nothing hit it it's a lying liar filled
with lies and death alright anyway I'm
gonna assume that once I hear otherwise
I did not need to go in that tunnel and
I did not need to find the room of
nightmares where he's gonna jump out and
kill ya
God also I don't know if I've mentioned
it before but the sounds in this game
are are pretty good too I mean if this
was developed by just one guy he's got
he is multi-talented to the extreme
number 1 graphics I mean the engine part
but obviously you know these obviously
weren't all pre-made he had to probably
made something himself so like it's just
amazing working the sound engineering
sound engineering is not easy you know
making all the art and doing all the
things and putting it all together into
one product that is absolutely Wow it's
hard to do some kudos to kudos to the
developer they're doing it all to make a
free to make a free game just oh that's
not disturbing at all
I think the mountain just farted and all
the lights have gone out good no no no
no no no oh I see that nope no no no no
that's a trap dad is a trap right there
that is a trap that meant you could have
kill me I see a green light over there
I'm gonna go to it but that is a dirty
rotten lie you lying liar
I know it's rap when I see one and I'm
not gonna trigger it for anyone not even
you okay this is only going green
because it's telling me where to go
okay is that the teddy bear oh no no
that's just it okay
Hey all right I got all the pieces I
think this might be this might be a way
through the bridge open that might be
the end of it but I think there might be
no there's another episode worth to
squeeze but I like to keep the ending
self-contained so I might I'm just gonna
wander a bit so see what happens
I still got a ways to walk before I get
back to the bridge man I did not like
when you think of a free game you do not
get the smut quality out of it if there
was a way like sorry that was way
overblown sorry I I really don't know if
I've disturbed my neighbors at all I
don't wanna sound gets through that door
window thing there and I just panic I'm
a big bubble blowing baby now deserve to
be brave okay things are okay things are
looking up and up I've got a backpack
full of bones actually I didn't even
have a backpack I just shoved him up all
my bum got a bum full of bones and a bum
full of stones stones and bones up my
bum and then I'm gonna take him I'm
gonna take the monster and I shove it up
his bum unlock the magic secret and then
go on my way home hopefully I think
that's how it's gonna work out
so nothing happened this is gonna make
me feel like I might have gone the wrong
way those are the woods from dark hell
and these are the woods from happy town
what happened what happened I stuff do
any bones in what happened I didn't see
what happened did I get hurt that
someone stabbed me [ __ ] someone trying
to take my bones you'll never get my
bones you'll never get my bum bones and
stones I need to stop rambling I have no
idea what I'm talking about
okay reg can I cross it now and if I do
what is the point
oh it seems so unsteady
[Music]
okay I'm pie hey that was much more
easier than I thought it'd be wow this
really is looking on the up-and-up okay
so anyway I'm gonna all right I'm gonna
I'm gonna cut it here so I'm gonna save
the ending for one one episode I had no
idea this game would like make this but
I thought this is gonna be a one-er but
35 episode yeah so anyway thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always what's going on over
there is that a rave
I got bombed bones I want to join your
I've got stones man in the next video
[Music]